dot org slash history
next on american history tvs the
presidency this november 22nd marks 49
years since president john f kennedy was
assassinated in dallas texas
the warren commission which investigated
the assassination concluded that lee
harvey oswald had acted alone in
shooting the president oswald was
himself shot and killed two days later
by jack ruby
numerous other theories have persisted
since 1963.
now a panel of historians talk about
what they think happened in dallas
this two-hour program was part of the
mid-america conference on history in
springfield missouri
well welcome
it's um
wonderful to be the moderator for the
mid-america conference on history
session
dealing with the kennedy assassination
with really um four of the leading
lights
who have been uh trying to get us to
understand what is the biggest murder
mystery
in
in us history
in um it's fitting that we're here with
and
the founder of this conference james
giglio has written the seminal book that
we use in colleges on the presidency
of john f kennedy
part of the university of kansas press's
uh
series on the presidency and it's a book
he constantly updates so james thank you
for doing that and i also might add this
is very timely unlike a lot of history
topics i don't have to explain to you
what the kennedy assassination was
nor probably do i have to remind you but
i will
that we are rapidly coming upon the 50th
anniversary
of the kennedy assassination in november
of
2013
i suspect you're going to be seeing a
lot of talk
about 50 years later because like pearl
harbor or 9 11 it's one of those moments
that anybody alive that that's alive
today that was alive in 63 has them it's
the moment they heard about the news and
people have stories and it's
endlessly fascinating already
books are coming out this november by
popular
television host and a scholar dealing
with the kennedy assassination i think
we'll we'll find more and more so we're
very lucky to have
these scholars here today the protocol
we're going to do is i'm going to call
them up one at a time according to
the program order they're going to have
about 15 to 20 minutes max
to talk then after all all four have
their say i'm going to go back in the
same order and allow each
gentleman 20 minutes i mean i'm sorry 10
minutes
um and at that point i might ask a
couple of questions and then we'd like
to open it up to q a from the audience
we have as you can tell from the program
two-hour session here so we should be
able to be able to get at some of the
questions
all of us wonder what happened all of us
are fascinated about the warren
commission and lee harvey oswald and
jack ruby i in a previous talk today
spoke on walter cronkite and how people
absorb the assassination via the
television they're just uh hundreds of
thousands of different ways to look at
this um tragic event
and um let's begin i'm going to call up
gerald mcknight
of hood college he's author a breach of
trust how the warren commission
failed the nation and why
and this is a ongoing inquiry for him
he's working on a manuscript right now a
new book on dealing with the kennedy
assassination for kansas
so
please professor mcknight
[Applause]
thank you for coming and i hope it's
going to be worthwhile trying to do best
i can
i want to begin this way
actually
what i'm going to do
uh is in brief overview
is to try to give you a sense of lee
harvey oswald's last 45 hours on earth
okay
now to begin with i just
want to begin this way
and that is to try to make as clear as i
possibly can how quickly how quickly
oswald was put in the frame
okay
as the assassin of the president
uh the assassin of officer tippet
and the man who wounded
governor connolly
um
now some of this would be would be would
have been very interesting in some ways
we don't i don't have specific
information but we do have accounts for
example
uh of the of the cat of the kennedy
cabinet people who were for example on
an airplane and were heading to tokyo
for a conference
uh back in washington there were only
four cabinet people left there mcmahon
uh mcnamara was one
bobby kennedy was another and then there
was the uh
gronsky and another fellow
minor figures the rest of them were
scattered across across the world now
those uh in in the air force plane that
was heading toward tokyo for a
conference that included uh that include
the secretary of state
uh his assistant robert manning
pierre salinger uh kennedy's uh uh press
secretary were in that plane accounts of
these people tell us that while they're
in that plane what they don't tell us is
the time is that they were they were
alerted to the fact that the president
had been shot
uh not only had he been shot but they
were also told that the one who shot him
was lee harvey oswald who had been to
the soviet union and he had done this
now i wish lovely to know exactly what
time that happened the president as you
know terms of central standard time was
killed by about 12 about 12 31 i think
so when he was shot 12 31 declared dead
at about 1 110 something like that
pierre salinger though in writing his
account
also contributed to the kennedy library
a manuscript and in that manuscript he
he indicated the time
on that plane they learned about this
information
uh that manuscript is in harvard i went
for there it is missing it is gone
nobody knows nobody knows nobody knows
where it is
back in the washington dc things
happened rather quickly at 3 40 central
standard time abra abram chavez
state department legal counsel received
a call from acting secretary of state
george bull ball
with directions to gather quote together
the files in the department on oswald on
lee harvey oswald that was a 340 central
standard time
he then tasked mr chavez chavez
to be sure that he had on his desk the
next morning a report on what the state
department had on lee harvey oswald
uh now we get to the more i think more
specific
indicators now of how fast this thing
this thing developed
at 12 45 central standard time 15
minutes after the shooting
a
dallas
lieutenant inspector by the name of j.h
sawyer with 23 years in the department
was on the police radio with a
description of the shooter
uh that is in the uh that's that source
there is in the uh fbi uh lee harvey lee
harvey oswald file
uh and the description was came this way
he was a white male approximately 30
years of age slender built 5 foot 10
inches and about 165 pounds well that
wasn't lee harvey oswald
and that he had a rifle
and that it looked like a 30 30 type
winchester
but no description on what he was
wearing
so my question would be that's
interesting
because if you become that specific and
then cannot describe what he's wearing
it suggests
you didn't know what he was going to be
wearing getting up that morning before
the event occurred that's
an indication of something that would
require i think
clutching at this issue again and
thinking it thinking it through but that
we'll leave a go with that
but what is what is equally more
interesting is that sawyer a 23-year
veteran on the police force
never was able he had the source gave
him that he said somebody came up and
told him that
but he never got the source's name
23 years in the dallas police department
and he never got the source in his name
um now oswald
at this particular time
was 24 years old he weighed 131 pounds
and according to dr rose who did his
autopsy he was five foot nine inches in
height okay so when he died when he was
when he was uh killed himself uh
on on sunday those were his those were
his uh vitals he no no description like
that on the top although there is
interestingly enough there is a there
was a cia file
uh they had several files on oswald one
was called the uh
lee henry oswald file and in that file
the dimensions you get for this fella
for the lee harvey oswald in this file
was that he was 165 pounds he was about
30 years old and he uh and he uh uh was
about five foot ten that's sort of
interesting i if anybody who's asked me
about that later like maybe i can make a
look i can explain that a little bit
more a little bit more length
um
the first i'm not sure this lemme won't
say it i'd ask dave kaiser about it uh
is i think some indication that maybe
the first
time the american people heard of lee
harvey oswald his name it may have been
from walter cronkite who was
broadcasting at that time but
uh i may have to go back and wait till
david kaiser is able to nail that debt i
don't know
in any event uh
so
that
that is just simply you know that's
simply an opening setting up uh i think
the spirit of the of the of the of the
times
now
what happened here next was it was it
was absolutely important
to find out
that that this description of the
shooter
that uh sawyer got
that that description of the shooter
came from
a physical source
and so while
sawyer could not satisfy us in terms of
the name of the person who gave him this
description
very quickly that name will surface
and it'll be the name of mr brennan
uh he is the commission star witness for
placing oswald in the frame for shooting
jfk governor and governor connolly
even though as i will go on a little bit
more even though the warren commission
had no credible evidence ever
that brennan was ever able to pick
oswald out of a lineup and i'll
explain a little bit of that a little
bit a little bit later a little bit
later as i move ahead here
um
now but even more specifically and this
is a document i don't think has has been
revealed yet
in terms of putting oswald in the frame
before any police had any forensic
evidence against oswald
at 1 40
on 1122
oswald was pronounced
jfk was pronounced dead about 30 minutes
before this
an arrest report
cited oswald as the man
quote the man who shot and killed
president john f kennedy
police officer tippet he also shot and
wounded
he also shot and wounded
governor governor governor connolly
if anyone you want to see this document
i have i have it up here
it's a 62 109.060 that's a that's a main
uh jfk file uh 2074 evidence behind file
uh and here it is and the date of this
is that the date of this week of this of
this
police report is 1
40 p.m central standard time
that is 20 minutes
after
jfk was pronounced dead at parkland
memorial hospital in 20 minutes
they've got oswald and they've got him
in the frame already
uh
that's wonderful that's extraordinary
extraordinary please extraordinary
policework
i'm not sure when oswald was arrested in
the texas theater
but it wasn't it may have been it may
have been after this i'm not sure
and i have to apologize but i have to go
back and and try to try to
check that out
well as it occurred uh since
since they needed
an explanation
for the identification of oswald
uh that sawyer then broadcast over the
police radio
uh
they needed a witness and uh
howard brennan becomes that witness
now the two points about brennan
could spend a lot of time on on mr
brandon the two points there is no firm
evidence that brennan ever was present
at a lineup
and picked oswalt out of the lineup
brennan makes that claim in time he will
make that claim
uh
in a book that he will that will be
published four years after his death
that he in fact did pick oswald out of
the lineup on eleven twenty eleven
twenty two but there is and that's in
the book that he had it was published
posthumously uh in a book uh called
eyewitness to history is where he states
he states that
but
if you go through the you know the
laborious work of going through the
documentation um
the most dramatic
uh rejection of that
comes when
captain fritz will say a little bit more
about fritz in a minute captain fritz
who was really sort of running the show
down there
was questioned by commissioner mccoy
john mccloy
uh of the wiring commission
about was he there
at the
time in the of the lineup
when brennan actually pointed to oswald
as the man he allegedly allegedly saw in
the sixth floor southeast corner window
with a rifle
and
discharging that rifle at the president
of the united states
and when he is confronted when he's
confronted when confronted with that um
fritz
could not answer mccloy he said well
i don't even remember if i was at that
questioning
he just flubbed it away it was so clear
that he found himself in an embarrassing
situation that mccloy dropped the
questioning
uh anybody who's interested if you have
the warranty report
go to the fourth volume four 4-h page
227 and check it out check it out
yourself
brennan's testimony was worthless
it was staged rehearsed and was
privately rejected by the fbi and the
warren commission behind the scenes
uh
now two important points i think would
follow here number one is
another man who appears on the scene in
on 11 22 is a fellow by the name of
charles leslie bronson bronson
uh was a engineer
he was in daley plaza on 11 22. he was
taking pictures of the presidential
motorcades that came off houston and
then turned on to elm
and that
and about a little bit by me five
minutes maybe before kennedy in the
limousine turned on onto
onto elm
uh he had a new camera and he was
panning in
on what had been the area where the he
would get a picture of the motorcade but
he this was a new camera and so he was
getting even more than that he was
getting the entire
uh texas school book depository
building and the sixth floor
uh
he had about 94 exposures of that sixth
floor window southeast corner is the
only window that is open on the sixth
floor it is the alleged assassins lair
where oswald is waiting for the
president
94 exposures he turned the though he
turned that information those pictures
over to the fbi if not the twenty
second the twenty third
uh the local fbi people looked at it and
returned it back to him and reported it
didn't his film his his film did not
even show
the texas school book depository
the word for that came from headquarters
bury that film which uh which they did
with which they did with dispatch uh if
you want a little bit more of that it's
in breach of trust i have it in a breach
of trust
uh
the uh
on december 1963
um
on december 1963
um
after oswald was dead
this
whole
official solution to the crime was
already now
already now uh
put together and and
resolved quote unquote
uh a couple of fbi agents back in
washington dc took a look at the
bronson film
and
now that the political issue is now over
it's resolved there's no problem with it
what they found out here and this is a
document you'd like to take a look at
let's show it to you
they found that the corner window on the
sixth floor of the texas school book
depository building shown in the bronson
film
showed no images
that could be interpreted as individual
or individuals who were found in any of
these exposures
the pictures do show an outline of what
may be interpreted as boxes
and were
later
behind behind the window now they didn't
stop there
they took the bronson films and then
they shuffled them off
uh to the u.s navy photographic
interpretation center
at suitland maryland which is probably
one of the best in the world at that
time
and the guys down there took a look at
it and reported the same thing there's
nobody in that window
nobody in the sniper's window they're
just simply images of
of
of book boxes which is what was up on
the which was up on the uh up on the six
sixth floor
um
that of course
is after
the whole case has been the whole case
has been
uh has been hasn't been has been has
been closed
um
did oswald fire a weapon that day
well very quickly i would just simply
say this once again i'm using fbi
documents
in september 64
uh the warren report was finished it uh
may had not gone public yet but it was
finished it was
in the printer's hands
and uh sometime
i don't know if the date is terribly
important here but uh
mr mr rankin who was uh who was the
chief counsel for the warring commission
i got a a a request
request came from um
an individual
uh stuart wolpert who was a head of
productions of
some larger movie uh company and he was
going to put out a movie a a documentary
called four days in november
and in doing that
he got to rankin and he said could you
run this manuscript past the fbi to make
sure there are no errors in the
manuscript
and the rankin got to hoover and hoover
said no i really will ralph did but he
said okay go ahead and so
in examining the
manuscript
went into the hands of mr belmont who
really was running the investigation i
think you have to appreciate it this
time hoover was
who was right on the edge of retirement
he was taking afternoons off napping
that kind of thing
he was not
exactly on top of the evidence but he
was interested in terms of the political
the political question here and that is
that oswald did it they caught him and
that's the end of the of the situation
so
belmont takes a look at the transcript
i'm sure he would he would rather have
done other things but since uh hoover
said go ahead and do it and
get uh get ranking off my back
when it comes to the
question here
the question was raised
uh about oswald there's a section in the
film in the transcript about oswald you
know being the shooter that day and
having having shot at the president
uh belmont says this this is fbi belmont
he said this is erroneous
as that these tests the parison tests
were essentially negative and our
laboratory experts have so testified
before the president's commission i
don't know where that was
in addition highly technical
examinations made by the atomic energy
commission in our laboratory on the
paraffin casts cannot connect oswald
with the rifle
cannot connect oswald with the rifle
now that's fbi
okay that's internal internal if uh the
internal fbi
situation here
give a minute more so okay okay
well a minute more all i can say is this
is that i was bored when he was in the
hands of the police
he was interrogated
i think eight times under interrogation
on those three days
uh lineups all that sort of thing
um under those circumstances
there is not
a record other than a record of those
interrogations of what was said and what
did oswald respond to here is
the crime of the century
and the individual who's held
responsible for killing the president
and the policeman mr tippett
and wounding a wounding conley
uh
not a word except we do remember that at
one time when he was
brought through police headquarters they
said you killed the president he said no
i'm just a patsy
i'm just a patsy
so
we have a situation here and the warning
commission had to ask
what kind of record did you keep in
these of these uh of this exchange
and captain fritz
who was in charge of this he said well
he said we didn't have a tape recorder
the dallas police okay they got 170 men
on the force we didn't have a tape
recorder he said we i put in
requisitions twice two years in a row
for a tape recorder and they denied them
to me
and stenographic records there was a
stenographer there but no stenographic
records
wine commission found no problem with
that at all
but what we do know here and i have a
documentation i'd be glad to show it to
you is that on 11 24
at sunday
oswald is killed in the basement after
warnings that there was going to be an
attempt on his life warnings came early
sunday morning to the fbi to the
sheriff's office and to the dallas cops
he still
instead of moving him out in the evening
a warning came and they and
two people said to him we don't want to
cause any problems we're going to kill
the son of a [ __ ] and so just you know
allow allow yourself to be reconciled
reconciled reconciled to that fact
now
all we ended up with then at this at
that time were two sheets of paper
written by captain fritz on this on
these seven or eight
inch interrogations
that's all that was left in at the time
of the at the assad at the time of the
at the time of the assassination and let
me just end with this
as soon as marina oz as soon as lee
harvey oswald was murdered on on sunday
just by those warnings i mean you know
the biggest latin american country in
the world here he is surrounded by all
these cops 170 news people
jack ruby comes in and bumps him off
uh
as soon as that happened the secret
service grabbed the hold of marina
oswald and her two children
and they took her to a safe spot
where they then after dinner
interrogated her it's on tape
for seven hours
now
did the was the secret service in on the
interrogations of course do they have a
tape recorder available of course what
has happened to all that information
it's all gone
hold on we don't know about it at all so
anyway those are some indication of of
lee harvey oswald's last last 44 hours
on earth
[Applause]
thank you
thank you very much professor mcknight
um next
up is david kaiser who has taught
history at harvard carnegie mellon the
naval war college and williams college
where he currently holds the stanley
kaplan visiting professorship
he is the author of numerous
articles and six books including
american tragedy
kennedy johnson and the origins of the
vietnam war
and
the road to dallas the assassination of
john f kennedy which he's brought with
us so we can see
and i'd like to interview or i'd like to
call up david
thank you doug and thank you jim for the
courageous act of putting together this
panel
i'm going to start with a couple of
brief remarks about the historiography
of the case so i can let you know where
i fit in
for the last
nearly half century the discussion of
the assassination has been dominated by
two schools of thought
or if you will two faiths
and i'm going to very briefly describe
each of them and how they approach
the evidence in the case
to begin with there's the church of the
lone assassin whose adherents insist
that both oswald and ruby were
essentially lone nuts
who murdered john kennedy and lee harvey
oswald respectively for their own
personal reasons and because they
believe this the adherents of this
church respond to any evidence of
conspiracy in the same way it must be
false
now in any complex case and this is a
very complex case one can always find
some reason to disbelieve any piece of
evidence if that's what you want to do
and indeed that is how trial lawyers
make their living
and thus
members of the church of the lone
assassin always find some way
to disregard any evidence of conspiracy
may i say that on one critical point
they are in my opinion correct
there is massive evidence that lee
harvey oswald did fire the shots that
struck john connolly and president
kennedy that he did kill kennedy and
that he was the only actual killer and
that was clearly demonstrated in various
ways by the house select committee on
assassinations in the late 1970s
but on why oswald and ruby did what they
did i part company with the church of
the lone assassin
now on the other hand on the other side
we have the church of the grand
conspiracy
and their adherents are frequently
rather vague about exactly what they
think did happen and who was responsible
but they're absolutely convinced that
there was a very large conspiracy
usually involving figures within the us
government and a massive cover-up
many of them argue that oswald was
innocent or at least that he may have
been
and their approach to the evidence is is
just as simple
any discrepancy in the evidence any
apparent lack of evidence
any evidence that isn't there that they
think should be is to them conclusive
proof of both conspiracy and cover-up
and since once again in a complex case
like this many discrepancies are
inevitable they have plenty to work with
too
may i say that both faiths are very ably
represented on this panel
but i do not happen to belong to either
one
now i first became involved in this as a
scholar on the 20th anniversary when i
was commissioned to write a long piece
for the sunday section of the washington
post
about the assassination
and at that time i took an agnostic
position
on the key issues but i was already
quite impressed by the conclusions of
the house select medium assassinations
namely that the president was probably
assassinated as a result of a conspiracy
involving organized crime figures
for the rest of the 80s and the 90s i
wrote books on other topics but then in
the 90s thanks to the jfk records act
we had a massive unprecedented and
probably never to be repeated
release of documents from the fbi from
the cia and from the assassinations
committee and that was an opportunity i
could not resist
and i went into that archive
beginning in 2001
determined to find out what i could
about the broader context within which
the assassination took place
uh i haven't read more of that archive
than any person i know but i think i did
with the help of some assistants read
more of it than any author
and here are my conclusions which are
similar to but much more specific than
those of the house select committee on
assassinations
president kennedy was killed by a
conspiracy of leading organized crime
figures including certainly senator
traficante the mob boss of north florida
who had previously owned many of the
casinos in havana carlos marcello of new
orleans and very possibly they're not
certainly sam giancana of chicago
those mobsters were part of a broad
network
including not only mob bosses but many
anti-castro cuban refugees
american mercenaries who worked with
those refugees and american right-wing
activists some of them leading business
figures
in saying that i want to make it very
clear that i am not saying that everyone
in the network was involved in the
assassination it is only certain
organized crime figures who can be
directly tied to it there are plenty of
suspects among the other groups but
nothing conclusive and actually i think
it was a relatively small group that
actually knew what was up
that network had been formed during the
batista era in cuba
when american mobsters were busily
turning havana into the las vegas of the
east coast
after castro took power it shifted its
base of operations to the us
and began to focus on castro's overthrow
and miami new orleans and dallas were
all
centers of network activity of many ways
of many kinds
crucially the network was enlisted in
1960 by the central intelligence agency
under the eisenhower administration
to assassinate fidel castro
three major mob figures trafficking
giancana and marcelo were involved in
that effort and as i have said at least
two of them were later involved in the
assassination of jfk
i also do not believe by the way that
anybody from the cia was involved in the
assassination although cia people worked
with key figures of the assad in in the
network all the time on the
assassination of castro in particular
now the motive for the assassination was
robert kennedy's all-out attack on
organized crime this had become the
major crusade of robert kennedy's life
in the 50s when he was the council for
the senate rackets committee and it was
his absolute top priority as attorney
general
carlos marcello
and sam giancana
were among his major targets
he came into office in january and by
april uh marcelo thanks to robert
kennedy and deported from the united
states kidnapped basically new orleans
and deported although he managed to
sneak back into the country a few months
later kennedy then started a prosecution
of marcelo for having submitted false
documentation and that prosecution
believe it or not ended with marcelo's
acquittal in new orleans on the morning
of november 22nd 1963.
sam giancana was another leading target
who was ceaselessly harassed by the fbi
and who the justice department thought
they had nailed on a wiretapping charge
involving his girlfriend the singer
phyllis mcguire
in 1962 but robert kennedy was appalled
to discover that he was going to have to
drop that charge because of john condo's
involvement in the cia assassination
plot against castro
now both martella uh
right
now both marcelo and trafficante
were also major allies of jimmy hoffa
kennedy's other major target and indeed
in may 1963
uh
hoffa sent frank regano a florida lawyer
who worked for both hoffa and traffic
county to meet with marcelo and traffic
county in orleans and to tell them that
the time had come to kill john kennedy
now you may be wondering why kill john
kennedy and not robert kennedy and in
fact it turns out that they had thought
about that rather carefully and reached
a sensible conclusion
were they to kill robert kennedy there
was a grave danger that the president
would send the army and marines after
them in revenge
but if they killed the president lyndon
johnson would take over
everyone knew that he and robert kennedy
were to put it mildly not close
and rfk would lose his influence and
probably his job
and uh some of the heat would come off
and that is in fact exactly what did
happen in the years immediately after
the assassination
meanwhile many anocra
anti-castro cubans and their american
supporters were increasingly angry at
president kennedy
after the bay of pigs and the cuban
missile crisis had failed to result in
the removal of fidel castro and by 1963
right-wing annie castro cubans and their
american allies all this is detailed at
great length in my book
were convinced either that jfk would
never do anything against fidel castro
or that if he did
he would replace him
with another relatively left-wing cuban
leader from the exile community who
wouldn't be any more to their liking
either and as a matter of fact about
that they were absolutely right that was
the goal towards which the
administration and the cia were working
during 1963.
however although there are certain annie
castro groups and individual figures
who have been linked to the
assassination and who certainly are
logical suspects there is no one about
whom i can definitely say that they were
involved
now what about oswald and ruby
and i want to stress that in the limited
time i have i'm only giving you very key
facts and if there are things you want
me to elaborate on please let me do so
later on
well oswald had connections to the
martello mob going back to his childhood
in new orleans he had an uncle whom he
re-established contact with in 1963 who
was a bookmaker in the marcel
organization and his mother also
consorted with men who were part of that
organization
i am also convinced as i explained at
length in the book that after oswald
returned from the soviet union in 1962.
he somehow became involved with
right-wing activists in dallas and new
orleans
and in fact became part of an ongoing
fbi
cointelpro effort to discredit the fair
play for cuba committee which i
discovered was definitely going on at
that time
and that is what his phony chapter of
the fair play for cuba committee in new
orleans was about again i am not
suggesting that oswald was being debt
was being directed personally by anybody
in the fbi
much of the cointel program was
subcontracted indeed to private
right-wing groups and that i think was
what was happening in this case
i am also convinced that when after the
fair play for
cuba committee episode oswald went to
mexico city in september of 1963
to try to get into cuba he was trying to
get into cuba
to make yet another assassination
attempt on fidel castro
one of my major findings by the way is
that the assassination plots against
castro run by the cia and others were
much more numerous than had been
revealed by the
investigations in the 1970s
when oswald couldn't get into cuba
because he couldn't get to mexico he got
back
he went back to dallas and he went to
dallas and he got the assignment to kill
jfk instead
as for ruby he had been associated with
mob figures all his life and his strip
club was undoubtedly a mob controlled
enterprise
dallas in the organized crime world was
a subsidiary of new orleans where carlos
marcelo was the boss
ruby talked for months before the
assassination about all the trouble he
was having with the american guild of
variety artists the union to which his
strippers belonged
even though there was an investigation
of that union that year most people
haven't understood what he was talking
about
that union did absolutely nothing for
the young woman who belonged to it
except collect dues it was a mob
controlled outfit that existed for the
purpose of extorting money from club
owners like ruby in other words ruby was
short in his payments to his mob bosses
he didn't know what to do and this left
him in a vulnerable position
but i now am going to go to the key
evidence in the conspiracy itself
the critical figure in making the
assassination happen
was an associate of the traffic county
family named john martino
he had worked in havana casinos for
traffic county he was arrested in havana
in 1959 for trying to smuggle some of
traffic county's money out although he
was charged with something else
and he was sentenced to a long prison
term
somehow he managed to get out of prison
in 1962.
at that time by the way in 1959 a
traffic conti
was also in a detention camp
in cuba
and he received a visit in september of
1959 in that camp from none other than
jack ruby who had made a short trip to
havana at that time
uh when martino got out of prison and
returned to florida in 1962
he immediately became very
active in the whole network again
he acquired a right-wing ghost writer
nathan weil and he wrote a book called i
was castro's prisoner and then in may of
1963 he organized with the help of the
miami cia station
and staffers of the senate internal
security subcommittee
and william pauley a industrialist uh no
a transportation magnet also
uh yet another assassination attempt on
castro which was known as the biopoly
raid
and according to a mercenary named
lauren hall who will come back to who
was also in the detention camp with
travis county in 1959.
both sam chunkana and traffic county
were involved in financing that raid
it was sold to the cia with a cover
story
involving potential soviet defectors but
it is clear that it was designed to send
a group into cuba with some equipment to
try to blow up fidel as it happened the
boat that they uh sent apparently sank
and the men never reached
cuba martino then went on a book tour
promoting his book visiting both new
orleans and dallas in september and
around october 1st
of
1963 and three weeks later he went back
to dallas for reasons that have never
been explained
we then come to lauren hall the
mercenary i just mentioned who had been
involved in the planning of the biopoly
raid and he was also in dallas
with another man larry howard
in late september and early october of
1963.
this was one of a number of trips that
hall made to dallas in 1963 usually to
raise money for andy castro cuban
activities
on october 3rd i can now say with
greater certainty than i did in the book
a left-wing refugee in dallas named
sylvia odious
left-wing cuban refugee
was visited by two mercenaries
claiming to be cubans
and friends of her fathers and a young
american who said very little whom they
called leon
and they asked her for help raising
money
uh
and she uh was non-committal a day or
two later their leader
who had called them himself leopoldo and
who i'm almost sure was lauren hall
called her to talk about as he put it
the american who had been with them and
he asked her if she could help smuggle
this american into cuba
because he was the kind of guy who might
take a shot at castro
he also mentioned that the american whom
he called leon
had said that the cubans should have
shot jfk after the bay of pigs
again sylvia odeo was non-committal and
said she didn't know how to smuggle
somebody into cuba
when she first saw oswald on television
after the assassination she immediately
recognized that it was the leon who had
visited her
it took the warren commission a long
time to get around to her she gave her
story to the fbi uh less than a month
after the assassination but they dropped
the ball
when she finally testified to warn
commission staffers among other things
she tried to get them interested in john
martino but they didn't pick up the bait
i now cut back to martino and to the
martino household in miami beach
where martino his wife and his 17 year
old son edward were
news junkies who watched both cronkite
and huntley brinkley every night
and one night in the weeks before
the assassination
one of the broadcasts made a reference
to kennedy's fourth coming trip to
dallas
i'm sorry to texas
if he goes to dallas john martino said
they're going to kill him
i have that from ed martino who came
forward with it not to me but i've
talked to him in great light some years
ago he is now a psychologist and a
consultant living in houston he's a very
responsible guy and he sat on this for
40 years
but this was uh confirmed also to two
other researchers by martino's widow
before she died
in addition
on the morning of the 22nd at breakfast
john martino looked at his son and said
ed you don't look very well to me today
i think you ought to stay home from
school
i'll be out working in the garage could
you keep track of the news and let me
know if anything happens
at around noon he did let him know that
something had happened and martino
immediately went into the house and
began making phone calls around the
country trying to link oswald to fidel
castro
later he tried to link ruby to fidel
castro as well
but this was unsuccessful
martino died in 1975 but before his
death he talked about his role in
assassination and the assassination to
at least two other men
one was john cummings a newsweek
reporter who had known for many years
and who i was able to interview
and he simply said that he had put it
together and that any castro cubans had
been involved
the other was a business partner named
fred claussen
who unfortunately was dead by the time i
got on the trail but claussen
had called the house assassinations
committee
late in the 70s and tried to and tipped
them off anonymously about martino and
about this and martino told him
that oswald was supposed to have gone to
a rendezvous
after the assassination where he would
have been assassinated and his body
would have disappeared
and i am positive that had that happened
uh there would have been rumors as there
were anyway actually that he had been
flown to mexico city and then to cuba in
an effort to provoke an invasion of cuba
the great irony is that although a lot
of the uh
leading figures in the administration
did suspect the cuba was behind the
assassination
nobody ever wanted to pursue that
as it was ruby had to be recruited and
he stalked oswald all weekend using his
police connections in the uh
and
in the police station and he was
recruited to kill him
in the mid 70s when the revelations
about the any castro
plots
first came out
it seemed that the story might break and
the church committee the senate
committee was getting fairly close
but sam giancana was the victim of a mob
hit before he could testify before the
church committee
that was virtually the same month that
jimmy hoffa disappeared as well
and a year later another key mobster in
the story johnny roselli
who had confided to jack anderson that
the mob might have been behind the
assassination
he went before the church committee not
for the first time and he finally linked
traffic connie to the assassination
plots
against uh castro he disappeared a month
later and his body was found floating in
an oil drum in miami beach sometime
after that
lastly in april 1977
a tabloid reporter called lauren hall
the mercenary i've referred to
at his home in california and tried to
interview him and the tabloid recorder
recorded the conversation and turned the
transcript over to the house committee
later
hall was very abusive and hostile and
declined to say anything but at the end
of the interview he made an interesting
remark
quote
hey man
right as it stands now there's only two
of us left alive that's me and senator
trafficanti and as far as i'm concerned
we're both going to stay alive because i
ain't going to say [ __ ]
traffic connie and marcelo both died in
bed but not before they had indicated
their role in the plot
privately
at least once each
now as i say
i had only 20 minutes
i hope i stayed within it and i had to
stress the main points
the book fills in the details on these
matters and a great many more and i'll
be glad to try to fill them up in
questions
uh
i wanted to see if the truth was out
there i concluded that it was
but i've discovered in this as in many
other controversial issues while there
is a market for the truth out there it's
a specialty market thank you very much
[Applause]
next up is professor david rowan from
the university of wisconsin at stevens
point he's the author of those a pruder
film
reframing jfk's assassination and we're
very privileged to have him here he's a
legendary teacher and scholar in
wisconsin
and beyond
thanks doug and thanks again jim giglio
for putting this together and all of you
at
missouri
well i approached this uh quite
differently
that uh
i think any us
thanks max
any any assassination
and in particular the assassination of
president john f kennedy has two
components
the first one one
is it is a simple murder
that must be investigated as any
ordinary crime to define the facts it is
largely answered answering to the
question of what happened to president
kennedy
on the other hand
it is simultaneously a political act
a violent change in government that
basically answers the question
of who shot him
the only clear and solid answer
to the imperative who
rests squarely on
the proper and exhaustive definition of
what happened to president kennedy
knowledge of the crime
shall forever govern the political
resolution
in dallas
the dallas police gave an almost
immediate solution to his murder
as professor mcknight has so aptly
shown us
and
within two hours they had announced the
arrest
of the assassin and named him as lee
harvey oswald
but within an hour of the murder
in washington d.c on the potomac river
j edgar hoover
director of the federal bureau of
investigation in his office without his
handlers present
in an emotional state
declared to justice department officials
that a lone assassin had killed john
kennedy and within two hours had
identified him as lee harvey oswalt
by mid-afternoon
the secret service in dallas had
concluded it was a lone assassin
two hours and 45 minutes after the
murder
air force one left dallas with jfk's
body
on route
over its communication system
came the network news announcing lee
harvey oswald a radical and a defector
to the soviet union had killed president
kennedy
in the evening
most of the intelligentsia of the
eastern coast
those are professors
college deans key newspaper editors and
like had embraced that finding
president lyndon johnson
in concert with that acting attorney
general
nicholas kutzenbach and director hoover
would
on early sunday afternoon
conclude
that ozil was solely guilty
and agreed on an investigation by men of
unimpeachable character to make the
evidence show it
within a minute after the last shot had
been fired
police had rushed into the depository
building
but incredibly although they claimed
otherwise
they never sealed the building
or the plaza crime scene although the
warren commission would concur with
their top officers by saying that they
had not only sealed it
but had closely guarded the building
the head of the dallas secret uh service
for example returned to the dealey plaza
at one o'clock
and he went into the depository building
and he found
that it was wide open no guards anywhere
and newsmen and citizens crowded into
the building roy truly the manager of
the building said
and
one television reporter
had his camera held for him on occasion
by police officers as he filmed the
search of the sixth floor
in the crowd of the traipsing unknown
evidence could have been tampered with
tainted or planted and the culprits
could have slipped out
as for the plaza it was never sealed
either
cars continued down elm street
the parking lots emptied the crowd
trampled sites where citizens
had reported bullets had ruffled the
grass
not only was the plaza area not sealed
it was neither searched nor protected
there were two grassy knolls two parking
lots scores of automobiles four streets
and several grass areas and a variety of
architectural ornaments
the importance of this failure can be
illustrated quite clearly
29 hours after the murder of president
kennedy
a visiting college student on the ground
on the
plaza found 25 feet south of the
place where john kennedy had been hit in
the head
a piece of his skull glistening
in the grass
and he picked that up and it turned out
a forensic radiologist
studied that and by the configurations
of the skull and other
aspects determined
that it could only have come from an
impact from the grassy knoll area or
from the front right
another illustration was uh
citizens found
on
north elm street to walk
a
six inch long
bullet scar one quarter of an inch deep
and his trough had lead in it and that
that disappears from the
evidentiary base there were only three
shots in the official
scenario and of those three shots
none of them would
to the
location
or the
nature of that one on elm street
sidewalk
when the police reached the sixth floor
of the dallas texas
texas school book depository
they discovered in the southeastern
corner a window partially opened
three 6.5 millimeter
shells uniformly laying on its floor
two inches apart
all with their heads appointed the same
way
and a number of book boxes that they
asserted the assassin set upon while
firing at president kennedy also they
claimed to have found a large paper bag
on the floor near the window that they
stated the assassin used to hold a rifle
disassembled in order to sneak it into
the depository
at 1 22 p.m
they searched the sixth floor they found
inside a wall of boxes a six point five
milliliter
cacao
rifle
the police announced as in an epiphany
that
the southeast corner was the exclusive
site used by the lone assassin
it was a fairy tale
ballistic tests had not been performed
on the
bit on the victims
not even the number of wounds or their
location or their nature on their bodies
were known
photographs had not been assembled or
looked at in fact
the police the fbi and the warren
commission shied away from those
photographs and some of them were quite
important for example one by a citizen a
slide
was showed that the first shot
in the official scenario that hit john
kennedy
would have had to have come through the
foliage of trees which could not have
happened
what to make of that assassin's lair the
official photograph or the window
opening shows a rifle could not have
been fired from it
and hit the limousine 60 feet below
without firing through two panes of
glass and the windows were unbroken
throughout the afternoon the police
calmly raised and lowered the window
while they decided on what frame would
be
best for the official
scenario
tests later showed that the three shells
had been also inserted and
ejected from an entirely different
carcarno
evidence of conspiracy completely
ignored by investigating officials
moreover the rifle was not swabbed to
see if in fact it had been fired that
day
nor had the shells been tested to see if
they had been fired recently
but the police lab found that oswald's
palm print was indeed discovered
on the rifle barrel when they took off
the wooden stock they said his palm
print was there
but
the print was flat the barrel round more
than that
at oswal's arrest the police
took his palm print for identification
purposes
and they took multiple copies of the
print
and their number
and their chain of possession were never
known and it's quite possible the police
could have
submitted a duplicate
as if from the rifle moreover
one of the fbi lab and ballistics
experts now these are some of the
world's finest scientists
testified under oath that the rifle
could not take prints
and another a bureau expert in a court
case
stated the metal was so cheap and porous
so irregular and
poor
it could not take a print
bizarrely there were four official
photographs taken of the assassination
of the boxes on the sixth floor
of those four they're all equally valid
as evidence
however
the warren commission finally selected
one to fit their scenario
but we know from examination of the
police photographer studebaker
that
the boxes had all been moved before they
took the photographs
but more than that
in one photograph he actually snapped
his own knee
and additionally
later scientific examination of the bag
by
fbi forensic experts showed that it had
never held the rifle not at all and in
the warren commission there's a
marvelous photograph it shows the area
where the bag was found
it's blank
and they had taken a pencil and dotted
in the area where the bag was was
allegedly found
now
then fingerprint evidence was also
involved here
and the one of the fbi
i'm sorry one of the dallas police
detectives picked up that bag and held
it in his hands there's a photograph of
it
at the laboratory they checked it for
fingerprints and the detective's print
isn't found only lee harvey oswald's one
print and he worked on the sixth floor
so it means nothing forensically
but more than that
they had a select worker
appointed to look at anyone who came
into the texas scuba depository he came
to work about seven o'clock and watched
every worker come in
and he testified under oath that oswald
entered empty-handed
he didn't carry a bag into the texas
school book depository but what they
leave out of course is his testimony in
in terms of the bag but also they didn't
search the adjacent shed and that's
where the workers left their
extra
clothing and bags and so forth and in
that they found a curtain rods
and
those curtain rods are now
found
two or three weeks later
and
as well oswald's room needed curtain
rods
and uh
it seems that 100 of the evidence shows
that lee harvey oswald did not in fact
carry that rifle into the texas school
book depository
police charged that after the murder lee
harvey oswald fled from his room
which was about a mile away from the
depository
his housekeeper stated that at 103 or
104
in the uh he came in at one o'clock at
103 and 104
she saw him outside
standing at the bus stop
right outside the
rooming house
according to the official
history he then walked a mile to the
south
and at the corner of 10th and patton
street
was confronted by police officer tippet
with whom he shot dead with four bullets
from a 38 that he carried
now
you have a lot of problems with that
and as far as i can see it's just an
invention by the police
for example
the
they said tippett was shot and killed at
1 15.
but there are four witnesses
that become invisible in the police
scenario and later the warren commission
affirms it
that they won't use them that said he
was dead by 106
and uh oswald could not have been there
by that time but more than that
the slugs in tipit's body four of them
they could not be linked to oswald's
pistol in fact
the evidence on that first lug is clear
as a bell no
more than that can you connect them to
the rifle shells the pistol shells
the problem with that is
the chain of evidence and the integrity
of those shells is so
difficult to follow
you cannot say one way or the other
but in addition early critics on the
scene
interviewed the policemen that's within
the same late late early early the next
day
and they said that that pistol was so
defective it could not even fire
the police the fbi lab said that it was
not
it had so many weaknesses they could not
make an impression on the primer on the
shelves
but more than that
this idea that he left from
his rooming house at 103 or 4
and walked to
the side of the murder
that's an invention
there is absolutely in the record not
one scrap of evidence i mean none that
he did that
it's inserted
but the but the police say we have three
witness to the actual shooting
one
helen markham
she was a
clear
persistent and dedicated perjurer
that's exactly what she was
the second one had seen oswald his
picture
in the newspaper and
had then picked him out of the keystone
cops type lineup that the police had
they had three men young men
in dress suits and ties
standing side by side oswald was up
there in a t-shirt
needing a shave had a black eye and
cussing them out said you're framing me
and
why you couldn't pick him out one
witness said you didn't even have to
know anything about the case to know who
it was
and
so it goes and the third witness they
had said he couldn't identify the person
those are your three witnesses
maybe we've got about a minute
that really
oh
no
all right
yeah
but the
the sum of it all is
i believe it was a conspiracy and it's
cons conspiracy means two or more people
shooting and there was a shot from the
front and a shot from the rear that
struck the oswald
us struck president kennedy
none came from the depository
and i don't know who shot him and i
don't believe that the evidence was gone
into sufficiently so we can answer the
what question
and for anyone to say who shot him i
believe
is
not good
it's not good
thank you
[Applause]
our fourth and final
speaker until we open it up and i know
where every listening of these you just
get more and more questions and
hopefully we'll have time to really have
at it here
um after max holland who is one of our
nation's top journalists and an author
editor of washington decoded which is an
online publication
he's a 1972 graduate of antioch college
and a contributing editor to the nation
and the wilson quarterly
um one of his he's written many books
one of the most recent ones is leak why
mark felt became a deep throat
also recently has done a book called
blind over cuba
the photo gap in the missile crisis
he's in the program as being the lead
producer for the national geographic
channel's documentary jfk the lost
bullet and he's editor of the kennedy
assassination tapes and he's currently
working on a narrative on the history of
the warren commission
uh out next year for the 50th
anniversary by alfred knuff
max holland
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you doug
i wouldn't blame you all if you're
thoroughly confused by now
before i begin i'd like to to thank
james giglio for organizing this panel
he's very persuasive and it's hard to
say
no to him
i want to start by saying i am the
dissident here because despite david
kaiser's modesty he is a high priest in
the church of the conspiracy
[Music]
i often say i'm the skunk at the garden
party because i've done this before
including with these
two of these gentlemen
i'm a defender of the essential accuracy
and integrity of the warren report
i don't believe it was perfect
or flawless
but sometimes i use the expression giga
good enough for government work
i don't believe
as the gentleman here do
that
as david
believes oswald killed jfk but in fact
he was going to kill castro
but that didn't succeed so he decided to
kill
kennedy instead and behind him was a
huge clanking conspiracy involving
dozens if not hundreds of people
i don't believe
like david rohn that more than three
shots were fired
and that oswald fired none of them
i don't believe like gerald mcknight
puts forward
that the single bullet conclusion was a
fabrication that the warren commission
was engaged in propagating an official
truth or really an untruth
and i don't even agree with the
moderator douglas sprinkley who has
blurbed these books
and called david rohns a brilliant
dissection of the zupruder film
and gerald mcknight's book
as shattering certain fundamental
assumptions
and that the warren commission was
engaged in gross delinquencies
now when i do these panels i invariably
have a problem do you respond to every
serious
and nonsensical statement that's been
made about the assassination
my feeling is if you do
you're playing to their temple kind of
like a basketball game who sets the
tempo if you respond
to everything that was raised
i believe you're you're lost before you
get started because there's so much
nonsense thrown at you
you wouldn't even know which end is up
the fact is
we live in an age of factual trusteeship
in other words who among you has the
time
to spend reading 888 pages of the warren
report plus
the 26 supplemental volumes that
constitute the real
warn report i dare say
maybe one if that
so you have to trust what's said by us
but i say up is up and they say up is
down so
what are you going to believe
my solution is to pick one problem faced
by the warren commission a major problem
the exact shooting sequence to show you
how they were both right and wrong at
the same time
and if you can understand that then you
can use that tool to also think about
the other things that the warren
commission did and perhaps fell short on
explaining
now the first conception of the shooting
sequence was offered by governor john
connolly from a hospital bed
in dallas he was there so he certainly
should have known what happened he was
of course injured
wounded almost
to the point of death
at the same time president kennedy was
killed he offered these observations
from his hospital bed
i think about 10 days after the
assassination they were shown on
national television during an exclusive
interview they were very
persuasive
his explanation was
he heard a shot
he immediately recognized it as a rifle
shot
he started to turn
to see what had happened to the
president because he immediately thought
of an assassination attempt
as he turned he was shot
now here you see
president kennedy already reaching
for his throat he's been shot
you're going to see governor connolly
wounded
he said by the second shot
very soon afterwards he slumps back
against his wife
and then the third shot sounds
and president kennedy
of course is hid in the head i won't
dwell on that very gruesome
picture
the fbi
when it submitted its report
to the newly formed warren commission in
december 1963 essentially bought
conley's reconstruction of events one
shot hit the president the next shot hit
governor conley the third shot
fatally hit president kennedy in the
head
now when the warren commission started
its work
they too read the fbi report and for a
couple weeks they believed it
then they realized that there was a
problem
the problem is
you cannot work the bolt
on the manliker carcano rifle
that oswald used fast enough
to get two shots off in the space of
time
defined by the zapruder film
in other
words oswald could not have fired a shot
that hit president kennedy and then
worked the rifle fast enough to hit
governor conley
so what's the solution
well either there were two shooters who
shot them independently
which is
would mean a conspiracy
or
that bullet went through both men
so when the warren commission restaged
the assassination in may 1964
they were either going to prove one
bullet hit both men
or that there have been two shooters
as it turned out
they decided one bullet hit both men
and here's a rudimentary
representation of that
and of course when you think about it
if a bullet entered the back of
president kennedy
and exited right above his adam's apple
near right about where
the knot of his tie was where did it go
if it didn't hit governor connolly that
would be a real magic bullet
and anyone who says the magic bullet
conclusion is not correct has to answer
satisfactorily the question
where did the bullet go if it didn't hit
governor connelly
of course it hit governor conley if
oswald used military ammunition
military ammunition is made to pass
through people according to the geneva
convention it's considered more humane
also it's more effective
shoot one bullet maybe get knock out
three soldiers on the other side he used
jacketed ammunition
so of course it hit governor
conley here's another representation
much more detailed
of the path of the single bullet
hits president kennedy in the upper back
is slowed
starts to tumble
because it's hidden object namely the
soft tissue in president kennedy enters
governor conley's black back
at an oblong
direction still hair has a lot of force
and momentum
shatters a rib
goes through his wrist and superficially
lodges in his thigh
and that was the bullet that was found
on a stretcher cart in parkland hospital
now if this is true
that means
one bullet missed because three shots
were fired three shells were found on
the sixth floor of the texas school book
depository and they were not neatly
arranged as alleged two were
in one direction and one was much closer
to the window
so one bullet missed
now it was a failure of the warren
commission
that they didn't spend enough time on
the shot that missed
because from their way of thinking
well it missed so
how important is it
they spent a lot of time proving the
single bullet conclusion to their
satisfaction and of course they had a
limited amount of time in fact they took
more time than they were supposed to and
people are getting impatient what's
taking them so long
lyndon johnson actually wanted the
report out
before the democratic i'm sorry before
the election
in 1964.
now the warren
commission also found something very
interesting
during the reconstruction
a marine like oswald was is taught to
aim at the upper body mass namely the
waist to the neck
that is what all good marines are taught
to shoot at
and when they did the reconstruction to
their surprise
they found that the president's
upper body mass presented itself
to oswald before the zapruder film got
started
that's why it says
not on the zapruder film here
they call that position a
and if they had followed that lead
they would have realized the possibility
that the assassination wasn't captured
in full on the zapruder film
but because of time constraints
they didn't now this is a picture
from a secret service training film
taken five days after the assassination
it wasn't to investigate the
assassination it was simply to show
agents as quickly as possible what had
happened
in order to prevent it from happening
again very soon
now what's interesting about this
picture this is from oswald's
perspective
this is the car in approximately within
a few feet position a
a very good shot the president is only
about 90 feet
from oswald
now what did the warren commission do
when it wrote its report
it came to the conclusion that one
bullet had hit both men
the single bullet conclusion and the
and the shot had hit the president of
the head and a shot had missed
now everybody on the commission
practically was a lawyer
and they thought
that the way to
paper up the fact that they didn't have
a single explanation was to entertain
all the possibilities
namely the first shot missed the second
hit both of them the third hit present
in the head
okay or
the first shot hit both of them
second one missed third hit the
president in the head or
the first shot hit both of them
the second one hit the president in the
head and the third one which is the
farthest distance just missed and if you
actually read the warren report page 111
it goes through each of these three
scenarios
the problem is of course it didn't
happen you know it wasn't rewound and to
see which way it could happen it only
happened one way
and the american people and critics were
expecting
a simple
explanation in fact they got this
thing only a lawyer
could write and appreciate
now as it turns out
the last scenario that the third shot
was the one that missed because it was
farthest away
was not true because most people
stated that the third shot was the one
that hit the president in the head so
although that was the most natural
scenario it didn't wash
the second scenario
the first shot hit both of them the
second missed because he was firing so
quickly
and the third hit the president the head
was put forward by the commission and
they said
this is possible we're not saying it
happened this way but it is possible to
get off three shots
in approximately six seconds
and this is
to their ever lying everlasting
consternation this is where the myth of
three shots in six seconds
came about now the warren commission
didn't say it happened that way they
just said it was possible well the fact
the fact is it was very very hard to
replicate the best marksman
had a very difficult time
firing that rifle three times in six
seconds and hitting the target twice
but there was also the first scenario
that the first shot missed
now the fact is
and it's ironic
because the only difference between the
fbi report of what happened and the war
on commissions was that the warren
commission correctly realized that the
rifle couldn't be worked that quickly
and so they came up with this this
analysis and they're ridiculed for it
this became the point of the biggest
point of can one of the biggest points
of contention
the so-called magic bullet
and in fact
if they hadn't come up with this
explanation they would have deserved the
condemnation
and distribute that they've fallen into
now
when cbs investigated assassination in
1967
three years later they were the first
organization to determine that conley
had been semi-correct that yes the first
shot was the one that missed he did hear
a shot
but contrary to what he thought it
missed it missed everything
it missed the president it missed all
the occupants in the car it missed the
car itself
and when i return after everybody has
a second round i'll tell you what
happened to that first shot
[Applause]
thank you max
and
we can commend all four of you because
you're wading into very difficult and
murky waters
on this topic and you all did it very
gallantly and we're all very
appreciative as i speak for fellow
citizens that you're all for
taking the time trying to help us
reconstruct what occurred in dallas i
would just say one quick anecdote i got
an opportunity to i was writing on
president gerald ford and i went out to
rancho mirage to interview him and have
lunch and he was very genial
man and i was really there to ask him
questions about his presidency mayaguez
incident or helsinki accords ended the
vietnam war
and he said come here i want to show you
something and he had a little group of
papers there he said you know what that
is right here
i said no he said that's the mail i've
gotten about my presidency he said you
see this stack here
that's what i've just got this week
people writing to me about the warren
commission report
and he said that's what people want to
know from me you're a rare bird asking
questions about history we are all
endlessly fascinated
what happened in dallas and it's only
human nature to want to find answers
john f kennedy when he went to my
university rice
50 years ago almost to the day when
september 12th so we're close here the
same month he said we go to the moon
because it's there and it's part of
human nature to want to go to the moon
well we want answers as humans too about
what happened at dallas and that all
four of you are foot soldiers in this
regard and we thank you
now we want we're running a little tight
on time mainly with that keem focus and
getting audience participation so we're
going to bring each person back to do
two things
right off the bat let us know do you
think oswald killed kennedy or not
and secondly to refute
information put out here or to take on
one of your colleagues on what you think
they may be
misunderstanding or misleading us and we
begin with professor mcknight if you
could come up um use the microphones
because this is being
recorded for c-span and
and other local media outfits
now am i open for questions i'll be glad
to handle take any you have is that is
that what
did you hear today
okay well uh
well david i listened carefully to what
david had to say
uh because that's um
i wasn't quite sure of his orientation i
i see clearly that his orientation now
um
and
if i have you right dave you do have
oswald as a shooter don't you okay
the problem i find with that is there's
no basis for that at all
uh and we could
we
we could go go from there i suppose
uh
look some
dave has his thing
and he's done a lot of research i know
he's been down the uh
down to dc national national archives
research
doing research down there
but he he doesn't bring in any of the
evidence the physical evidence
the autopsy
uh
in a case like this even if even if it
was just joe banger who was off the
street
and you want to know what happened to
him probably the best evidence would not
be
would not be people's memory of this or
you know
that that kind of stuff the best
evidence is forensic in this case would
be the
autopsy and i didn't hear uh i didn't
hear dave mentioned the autopsy the uh
the autopsy of john of john f kennedy uh
at all
no as a matter of fact i didn't hear it
with
max either
uh
that would tell you something i think
about
about the shooting where it came from
and what we have to understand for
example let me let me just i don't
go on and on about it but when that body
when when when kennedy's when kennedy's
body went to park memorial hospital
uh the doctors there
had no
had no political ambitions
i don't know if they voted democrat
republican we don't know
but when they looked at that body and
there were there were a host of them
there in addition to nurses
they for example looked at the neck they
he had a puncture
wound in the neck
before they did a tracheotomy over that
they looked at it now these are these
are doctors in dallas
dallas is a hut ding dong town shooting
goes on all the time fridays and
saturday places mob with victims of
shooting okay these guys
these guys see see corpses and they see
people with bullet wounds constantly
when they looked at that fro that wound
in the throat they said
not knowing what the official story was
going to be they said immediately that's
a frontal wound uh we'll do a
tracheostomy over to relieve the
breathing all of them agree to that
all of them later on when questioned who
were in that room said the back of the
president's head was blown off
blown off
that came from a shot from the front
uh in terms of in terms of in terms of
ballistics every one of them the nurses
and the doctors all look back there said
there's a massive exodus back over the
right ear
okay
so
this is this is the way they uh they
left that lay that that situation
uh if you continue along if you continue
along those lines in terms of kennedy in
terms of kennedy's wounds
um
the first one to
the death certificate
that was that was composed by dr berkley
who was kennedy's physician
now this is before the politics of the
case
has descended over here dr berkeley when
he looked at kennedy and when he had an
opportunity at parkland mental hospital
to do a birth to take a look
and write a death certificate
uh he looks at the uh he looks at at
jfk's at jfk's wounds and he has
in in the report he gives he has the the
wound in the back at the third thoracic
vertebrae
third thoracic not cervical
ultimately in order to
orient
politically
the fact that a shot came from the rear
that thoracic wound is moved up to the
neck
it's a migrating wound i guess that does
happen now i don't know of any i don't
know of any
official
uh
account of that happening in police
office but but that's that's where it
ends in when the report is submitted it
is no longer a third thoracic vertebrae
it is a cervical vertebrae that was
important because then this neck wound
entry wound becomes a wound of
exit
because the shooter
and nobody has demonstrated to me
that oswald neither of these two fellows
here that oswald was in fact on the
sixth floor the evidence is he was not
on the sixth floor the evidence is he
was in front of the building i won't go
into that i won't go into that but there
are people who saw him in the front of
the building
uh and and it's too long it's too much
to go into but but i'm satisfied in my
own mind in terms of the evidence uh
secret service evidence and other
evidence of people who are on those
front steps it was lee harvey oswald who
was the man in the doorway i don't know
if you know anything about that uh
lovelady is the guy that the commission
appoints to that position but it's
oswald the reason is because he can't be
on the sixth floor and on the first
floor at the same time but that's where
he was as far as as far as i'm as far as
i'm concerned
ultimately we end up with a situation
as max had delineated here in terms of
his view
of three shots were fired
uh two hit
uh one missus has to go down range to
account for a tag bullet there was a
bullet scar on a when i on a curb down
under the overpass where jim tegg was
standing uh the dallas police
sheriff's office were down there they
examined they said yes there's a bullet
that's a bullet a bullet smear on that
curve uh ultimately that curve will be
patched okay before there's any
examination of the see there's any
copper or anything like that
so that there are three shots fired two
shots hit
and
the bullet that
is the non-lethal bullet at the one that
hits kennedy in the head
the bullet that's a non-lethal bullet
399 that's recovered
recovered it is in virtually pristine
condition
a little bit of flattening
and yet that is the bullet
that
goes allegedly now as the moon the wound
is moved up even jerry ford gets
involved in this later on he he'll he'll
move the wound up on the back for
neatness purposes
he's as he says he's caught on doing
that and he said i just did that for
neatness purposes
uh so we we end up with a situation
of a bullet that
gone through this is the bullet that
will have gone through jfk will have
gone through connelly and will have will
blow out his left wrist there is a hole
in his left wrist and when that bullet
ends into evidence
it is in virtually pristine condition it
is a little bit flattened now i have to
i will end this
uh just
yeah it may just end it this way in
terms of my own limited experience uh in
5152 i was in korea i was in grave
registration
you went out rounded up
that early part of the war uh the the
campaign was raged with the chinese uh
sending masses of troops uh to just
simply overrun
our men in the field
uh
and so you had this incredible hectic
home of bodies all over the place
and so both sides u.s and the chinese
called a truce and i was with the grave
registration people and i would go out
there and clean and help clean up
the body it was incredible we had little
chinese flags we put them on the chinese
dead bodies the chinese had little
american flags sort of like coming out
of
out of a a a
liquor glass or something they put on
american bodies but but when you saw
what ammunition can do to people
now this is military ammunition okay
but still
399 could not have inflicted those kind
of damages
on connelly's wrist and remain
and remained in pristine condition every
doctor who looked at that case
even ultimately the three autopsies or
the three doctors who at bethesda naval
hospital two of them hadn't seen blood
in year they were administrators they
did the autopsy they did the autopsy and
the reason they did the autopsy because
they were military and they were under
military control at the time that
autopsy was done
and so they didn't do a thorough autopsy
at all they were not allowed to they
were curtailed
so these are some of the problems i have
with
my colleagues here max and with david
okay
thank you very much
david kaiser come in and he's
established clearly he does not think
lee harvey oswald
killed kennedy he thinks he was a patsy
um but maybe one way expanded a little
david take on you rebuttal but also one
thing that all i've been haunted by why
once oswald was captured and he was the
killer of kennedy why when he was
interrogated was there is there no
record tape recordings or writing
always don't understand that part of it
all right that that first there's no
tape recording but there is a record
i've read the record many times there's
a record of the question and answer
um
now
there are two odd men out
in this whole argument
well actually as one man me and and a
committee of the house of
representatives and his chief counsel
robert blakey
who was a friend of mine insofar as
somebody can be a friend who you've
never actually met face to face
um
and we have
a number of things in common but one of
them is that we're
not liked by either the church of the
lone assassin or the church of the grand
conspiracy and they don't quite know
what to do with us because now
i mentioned the assassination committee
because
they looked very carefully in every way
they could into the issues of autopsy
ballistics where kennedy and connolly
were sitting and everything else in the
late 70s their reports online in several
places now you can read every separate
report
and they reach very clear conditions at
conclusions
that yes uh oswald's gun did fire the
bullets that yes
there were only two bullets that hit
that they came from the same gun that
they came from oswald's gun and that
there was no shot that hit from the
front
uh and that's why i didn't feel it
necessary to go into all that and i
still don't
now
uh all i can say to you max is
that
it's amazing to me that you're not even
willing
to confine your criticism to what i said
and that you couldn't resist saying that
i was part of the church of the grand
conspiracy too and that and i quote
you said that i said that oswald was
part of a conspiracy involving dozens or
hundreds now let me ask for a show of
hands in this room how many people heard
me say that oswald was part of
conspiracy involving dozens or hundreds
please raise your hands if you heard
that
thank you
i specifically said when i referred to
the network that i was not saying that
everybody in the network was involved i
named three people who i said were
definitely involved i mentioned that
every one of those people to greater or
lesser extent
to a greater or lesser extent or more or
less reliable extent admitted that they
were involved and that's all i said i
said there were other suspects but
that's all i said
there's nothing else really that i can
say based on what the other panelists
said but i hope i'll have time to take a
question or two about any aspect of what
i said from you all
the other david come on up
and also i'm wondering is there any
going with the 50th anniversary is there
any more footage or photography that's
being found what do you know what are
the new artifacts being found from that
day in addition to challenging some of
these guys
uh i'm not familiar but with any but the
old is sufficient
that's all you need
so my basic uh observation is that uh
lee harvey oswald was
not involved in the shooting
of president kennedy
i believe that he was an orwellian in
political orientation
he was anti-marxist anti-communist
anti-socialist
he had an intelligence number of 110-449
and we know many other aspects about him
as far as i can tell he's not related
to anything
devious he seems always been patriotic
but with respect to max holland's
observations i've read everything he has
written from the 1990s on
and i've gone over them all with
fact check
and i must say that
they match what he presented here today
and
almost every fact he presented will fall
upon the
most casual
reference to the evidentiary base
that this shot here
this single bullet theory
was
came in june it came after they couldn't
resolve the teg shot
and to resolve that tank shot which was
brought forward to the commission
by the
u.s attorney in dallas
to the commission they had they had to
do it someone in authority had said
there's another person shot here
so they came up with that single bullet
theory had been cooking in the back
burners for a while but they did that
but more than that
this depiction of the wounds on
on the kennedy this throat wound
during the autopsy they didn't find it
it's after the corpse had left the
morgue
and they phoned dallas
they were told there was a bullet hole
in the front so
the autopsy doctors just put one in they
and
they made it a
exit wound not an entrance wound but
every medical authority every medical
doctor
every surgical nurse said it was an
entrance moon there was about three
millimeters
circle with a bruised wing bruise ring
and these are experts in ballistics
and uh
his wrist wound that was from the grassy
knoll this is by joseph dulce dr joseph
dulce as a military surgeon
and the
thigh wound is part of the single bone
theory
we know from the x-ray
radiologists and so forth
that there was no bullet hole in
kennedy's left leg
there was a tiny flake
and we know and they got around that by
not calling the surgeon who who looked
at it to testify
well the warren commission
deliberately
knowingly
willfully
were trapped
and i think it's one of the great crimes
of history that people don't come
forward to defend the chief justice
and in terms of them being lawyers you
left out i believe one of the most
interesting points they didn't have the
adversary proceedings were there's no
adversary present it was all secret and
no one there to question things and as
whitmore said the great intellectual
the adversary system of justice is the
greatest invention of the human race
and it's missing and i think that's
the achilles heel of the horn commission
i regret i didn't have time to go over
each of my esteemed colleague max
holland's points one by one
but i would love to do it
um
the reason i'm asked about new um
information in the last couple years
just maybe about half a year ago now six
months ago they have found the tape on
air force
one
going from
from dallas to washington dc which had
been edited by the warren commission now
they have the full tape
so there is constant flow of bits and
pieces
that are coming forward what they all
add up to is another another story
max you've got plenty too
plenty to re defend and
go for it
well let me just say in response to
david anybody who reads his book
it has a cast of dozens if not hundreds
of people who were culpable in the
assassination according to his analysis
he didn't say exactly that this
afternoon but read his book
now here's a picture
altered
from the secret service
yes i have
here's an
altered picture from the secret service
training film and stills that was made
five days after the assassination the
ghost car
standing in for the presidential
limousine
is the approximate position within a few
feet
of the president's car when zapruder
started his camera
now that's important because it's not
generally recognized that zapruder's
film actually has two segments
the first segment
of about seven seconds
consists of motorcycle policemen driving
by
and film in those days was precious
plus his camera was hand wound with a
spring
so when all he did see was motorcycle
policemen driving by he stopped his
camera and he waited until he was sure
that the president was in view
this is frame 132 from his film
this is frame
133. the car is much further into dealey
plaza
than was commonly understood
he never said
he never pretended that he had filmed
the car making the whole turn
in fact if you read his testimony he
said he only heard two shots
so my explanation
for what happened
and it's not shared by everyone of
course
is that oswald being the good marine
that he was
fired a shot before the zapruder film
started or restarted to be technical
because oswald fired at the upper body
mass
now there were interestingly there were
two witnesses one
way back here
and another at the other side of this
architectural feature in dealey plaza
who said in their very early statements
to the dallas authorities when the first
shot
sounded the president was passing a
black and white highway sign now this
sign is no longer in dealey plaza it's
the old u.s highway badge signs black
and white
so what am i saying here oswald fired a
shot
when it was suitable for him because you
have to remember the zapruder film
mesmerized everybody to the point where
it became the representation of the
assassination you can't think
of the assassination without seeing it
through zapruder's eyes but of course
oswald had no idea zapruder was there he
had no communication with him he didn't
say he didn't have a walkie-talkie and
said abe are you ready i'm going to
start shooting
he shot when it suited him
and therefore the first shot
was fired before zapruder restarted his
camera now what does that mean
in terms of an explanation
the first shot missed i believe because
it hit that mast
overhanging elm
street that would account for the jacket
separating from the lead core of the
bullet and several witnesses said they
saw something strike the pavement at the
moment the first shot sounded
then the lead core
goes down into dealey plaza
it hits this concrete skirt around a
manhole cover
other witnesses said there was a burst
of dust around that skirt
and then it hits this curb that was
referred to earlier where a witness
named james tayg was standing nearby
and he had some blood on his cheek
either from a piece of concrete from the
curb or possibly the lead
core and that's what i believe happened
to the first shot now what's the
importance of that
if the timing is as i believe it is that
means oswald fired three shots in a
little over 11 seconds
which is eminently doable
easy
for even a marine
of his riflemanship
so what am i trying to say here i
believe the warren commission
missed an opportunity
to present a clear convincing
single explanation
of what happened
now i talked to several the war and
commission staff members some of them
are indifferent to this explanation they
say well we got the shots that hit the
president correctly and yes they did
and you can't dispute that
but if they had identified what happened
to the first shot
then there would not have been none of
this six seconds in dallas business
which is a mem that people still
remember
and there would have been an explanation
that would have been persuasive about
the shooting sequence
now of course that doesn't explain all
the other problems and issues that have
to be gone into but i'm suggesting
that it's a way of looking at the warren
commission you cannot impeach their
findings even if i'm correct it doesn't
impeach their findings it improves
on their findings
and that is the way to look at the
warren report because it has never been
impeached
been impeached and it never will be
thank you
we're going to have questions in a
moment if you'd come up to the
microphone and i just want to get we're
carrying both um david kaiser and max
holland you both are saying that you
believe lee harvey oswald killed kennedy
he would seem to be of a of a one on the
big issue
but there's a um bad energy between you
two
and uh
what what is it um max that you're
you're you feel that david is
mispresenting that you the and david
what is it that you feel max is since
you both on the seminal part of oswald
being the killer on the same page
well there are two important questions
on the assassination first who killed
the president who was responsible for
the shots fired in dealey plaza on that
david and i agree
the second question though is even if
oswald did the deed
did he have help were there people
behind him was he part of a larger
conspiracy that's where we differ
david
went through all the records or many of
the records at the national archives i
tip my hat to him but he concocts
information when he wants to he
resorts to some of the things that jim
garrison dredged up in 1967 the rose
shimmery incident and to give you an
example of how he ignores information
when it doesn't suit his purposes
lee harvey oswald tried to kill a
right-wing general
named edwin walker in april 1963.
now from oswald's perspective killing a
general who he thought was american
hitler
and killing president kennedy was not
all that big a stretch because both
represented american imperialism and a
threat to castro's cuba
but for most americans of course
it had a lot of dissonance walker and
kennedy
well in david's book
he says he really doesn't understand why
walker would be a target of oswald and
to me that's a fundamental
void
misreading of oswald he presents oswald
as a cipher completely devoid of any
motivation designs of his own anybody
who reads about him and they're very
good books including one by norman
mailer
about oswald you can't treat him as a
cypher
and get in line guy anybody we'd love to
get some questions to just stand up
there
all right
one of the things that you have to
understand if you're going to be a
serious historian about anything is that
just because a crazy person
like jim garrison believed a certain
piece of evidence
doesn't mean that that evidence is false
i didn't say anything was true because
jim garrison said it was true
everything that's in the book and and
those points that max
is talking about aren't critical to the
main argument anyway but i stand by what
i said anything i said was based on the
original evidence as it appeared
uh and it's and i made very clear what i
thought about the garrison investigation
which is pretty much what max thinks
about it
um
i'm sorry what was the the last point
you were making was oh yes about walker
yeah
actually i had some new information
about it which is in there um
i'm not so sure that oswald tried to
kill walker
i'm sure that oswald's shot at walker
i will say that if oswald had attempted
to kill walker with the same
determination that he attempted to kill
president kennedy walker would have been
dead
oswald just fired one shot didn't hit
him and apparently ran away it is a
mysterious incident open to several
possible interpretations
but uh i'm not going to try to spin that
out
now
um
again
i'm willing to let my
use of evidence
be judged by any impartial person
there were many times
in the course of writing the book in the
course of writing the research
when i found myself kind of grinning to
myself and thinking gee if i wanted to
prove that the cia or lyndon johnson was
behind this i could do a better job than
anybody else has but i didn't because
that isn't what i thought
um oh yes as for oswald being a cipher i
don't think that's really what i said i
do think oswald is an extremely
enigmatic figure
um
that the problem well no the what
happened was that i discovered
as i said that oswald's whole
performance in new orleans
with respect to the fair play for cuba
committee
fit
perfectly
into
what the fbi was trying to do to the
fair play for cuba committee at that
time namely to discredit it and portray
it as a communist front
and i found a couple of other things
which i want to mention because i
thought they were highly significant
a day or two after the assassination an
assistant director of the fbi wrote a
memo on what we're doing about the fair
play for cubic committee and he talked
about the cointreal program that they
were running how they infiltrated it how
they were trying to start feuds within
it and how they were trying to discredit
it in the press and that's what oswald
did he successfully established
wittingly or unwittingly if you will
by his radio appearance in new orleans
that it was really a communist front and
that he had been to the soviet union and
that uh and so on but anyway
um now so that memo
laid that out
a new copy of the memo was prepared for
the attorney general on what we've been
doing about the fair play for community
cuba committee it was the same memo
about the fair play for cuba committee
but the co-intel program part of it was
left out
second thing 12 years later 1975 the
church committee is looking into
cointelpro in a big way and the fbi
tells them a lot
about how it was done
and for instance that they discredited
the du bois club in some southern city
by founding a fake chapter of the du
bois club exactly what oswald did with
the fair play for kubrick many
and
the fbi submitted a list of targets
but they left out the fair play for cuba
committee from the left
from the list of targets that was in
1975.
i don't think i'm a chronically
suspicious person but
i can't help but think that maybe
somebody at the fbi was worried that
it might be
might open up some unpleasant avenues of
investigation
if they were to open that up
again as to who was involved in that
as to who might have been in that
there's a lot more in the book there's
one figure actually in the book
who had been the staffer for the senate
internal security subcommittee
briefly he had been a university
president in dallas he ran his own
anti-communist organization
and his name was dr robert morris
and uh some evidence came to light
after the book came out that linked him
very closely to lauren hall
and uh he
there are other things and and he's
somebody i'm a little more curious about
with respect to the counterintelligence
efforts that oswald might have been a
part of the other thing is
read the letters oswald wrote
to the fair play for cubic committee to
the communist party of the u.s
uh to the socialist workers party trying
to make contact with them
um
and
see how they responded to them
and
it is clear
a
that they thought this guy was nothing
but trouble and he was probably an
infiltrator and b that they weren't
going to have anything to do with him
and that's what happened with the fair
play for cuba committee in new york he
wrote a letter saying i want to start a
chapter
and the guy said well you're in a very
dangerous place in new orleans and i
wouldn't get too out in the open and i
wouldn't rent an office
and and oswald writes back and says well
i did go ahead and rent an office and i
hope to do good work from the cause and
that's it
i mean ted lee in new york the head of
the committee
he sizes it up this guy has nothing but
trouble i'm not going to have any more
to do with him and he doesn't write him
and in the same way when he shows up in
the consulate in mexico city
trying to get into cuba he presents his
evidence of his fair play for cuba
committee
um activities to sylvia duran who's a
mexican working in the cuban council and
and he says see i'm this great friend of
castro let me into cuba
and as she explained to the house
committee she's sitting there thinking
this isn't right this isn't the way
americans do it
americans go to the communist party
headquarters in new york and they get
vetted there and i hear from the
communist party headquarters from new
york
and i'm ready for i'm ready with a visa
when they get there and uh so she tells
him i'm sorry i can't help you but maybe
if you get a visa to go back to russia i
could get you a visa
then and and so on so
that's the kind of thing i've done i
didn't start with agenda with an agenda
i wanted to see what i could find and i
was very surprised by how much i did
find and and the patterns i found that
this fit into thanks
[Applause]
all right we go thomas tube a question
there in the front go ahead and start it
off
i do uh
i want to commend you for trying to make
sense of
this complex issue i think if we stayed
here all day we would not get through
half of what you raised
and
with that in mind i'd like to uh address
my comments to professor mcknight since
you opened us up you started with the
707 flying
to japan over the middle of the pacific
and part of the conspiracy theory
analysis is that one reason that the
assassination took place when it did
is that it was done at a time when a
significant portion of the senior
cabinet was away secretary of state
uh secretary of treasury uh dylan and
you're on the list
uh
one problem with that and i'd like you
to comment if that's what you're trying
to trying to uh to convey
is that we know from the records that
the japanese in effect set the time when
they could actually sit down and engage
in a trade mission so if there's
conspiracy are you suggesting that the
japanese are involved in some way
secondly secondly
secondly uh you also talked about the
timeline
well there there are logs uh of flash
traffic
that come in and it and from the what
the record indicates from both rusk and
and dylan who disagree with each other
on what should have been done they agree
that they didn't know what was going on
first they debated for some time what
was it take place i don't remember the
exact time that the message came in the
second message was the one that
indicated that not only was the
president
hit but that he was mortally wounded and
it's at that time they decided to turn
around and fly back so i'd like to in
other words are you saying that all
these guys on the on the plane were also
in some way shape or form uh involved in
a conspiracy
please
use that you can stay here okay
we only have a few minutes no i'm not
saying that at all
as a matter of fact i was not even
considering putting that in in a sense i
wanted to get to the fact that in in
dallas itself
uh oswald's in the frame
20 minutes after the president's is
declared it is declared dead
uh so
there there is something maybe one could
say here is that
the air for air force one tapes which
would include lyndon johnson leaving
leaving uh
uh leaving dallas and coming into
andrews air force base
uh there's still a lot
of
back and forth i think there were four
circuits going on that plane
and what we have right now maybe is 40
of what was said uh there is
being held by some
uh it's this is clifford uh
clark clifford who was not clark
clifford i can't think clifford's first
name uh was
lbj's
was lbj's assistant
uh world war ii veteran a wonderful
record all that
uh when he died he left the entire
transcript
of what took place on air force one
which
if we get it if we ever do get it
becomes public it should be very
interesting
because it may say something about
lyndon johnson who was he talking to for
example
was he insisting that kennedy's body not
go to beth not go to uh
excuse me
uh that kennedy's body not go not go
that kenny's body go to bethesda naval
hospital because there he will get a
military autopsy and that would mean it
would be a controlled autopsy okay that
would be important i think i i think uh
doug horn has done a lot of work on that
uh but i wasn't implying anything here i
was just sort of fitting filling in
color material and would be it would be
interesting to know where
when this won this group of the of with
gene rusk and manning and the rest of
them on that flight going to japan uh
exactly what time were they told
that the suspect in the case was lee
harvey oswald a defector to the soviet
union
i don't know when that was but i do know
when the dallas police
had oswald as the man in the middle and
that was at 1 40 central standard time
and that's
that's just 20 minutes after the
president was that's that's a
significant document that's 20 minutes
after the president himself has died
could i add one other thing in terms of
the last question
we're going to have one last question
and then i'm just going to ask each
person on the panel just
one
title that they wish people would read
not one of their own books but one other
last question
thank you i appreciate the panel
my question
has to do more with
in two cases i've had people tell me or
in the conversation about the
assassination of kennedy
who do you think hill kennedy and they
would say president johnson
now here's my question though i don't
believe
i don't want to argue that he did that
but this ties professor brinkley to your
discussion on walter cronkite
trust
to what extent
did the
assassination of president kennedy and
the warren commission
and maybe its failings impact the trust
that the american people have
of their government
and how is that evidence of why we're
having this panel here today
in going back to marines burning the
thatched roofs in vietnam and that being
aired
could the assassination and the
investigation of that assassination have
laid the groundwork for that
failure of trust that has occurred
between the citizens and our government
that i was going to that has max holland
written all over it since he's got a
book on the warren commission coming out
well that's a very good question
there's no doubt that there's a direct
relationship between the loss of trust
loss of trust in government
and the kennedy assassination if you
look at all the polls
for the first two years after the war
report came out
the trust level remained high but by
1966
with the war in vietnam
and people mostly from the left picking
at the warren report
and some inexplicable things that the
shortcomings of the report which i
didn't have time to get into
that's when i mean people belie if the
government can't tell the truth about
this you know what else is it
but let me just say this
i was driving down here
i was listening to jacqueline kennedy's
conversations just released a couple
months ago
and she talked about how the first
dinner outside the white house with the
home of john sherman cooper and his wife
lorraine in georgetown
you might not remember but john sherman
cooper was on the warren commission he
was the republican
senator
he was such an honest politician that
the first time two times he ran for
senate he lost
because he was so terrible a politician
but when he was appointed to the senate
he became beloved by kentuckians and he
was a very esteemed member of the senate
and a personal
friend of president kennedy
now anybody up here who says that the
warren commission was corrupt
incompetent i submit to you how do you
explain that someone with john sherman
cooper's integrity
would be part of something corrupt or
incompetent he never renounced the
warren commission
here we have the last last word you can
stay there
diametrically wrong last word right here
we gotta go i'm getting cuts chief
justice warren himself didn't believe in
the warren report he said so after after
it and lyndon benz johnson said so
during in the white house and afterwards
and john sherman cooper and richard
russell two members of the warren
commission voted
did not believe it itself and hail
bogged a member of the warren commission
and
yet another
they didn't believe in their own
uh commission report four out of seven
didn't believe it
but i think max has been studying it so
long he's a victim of a stockholm
syndrome
okay
see uh
well we're done i'm gonna stop it's like
charles sumner in the civil war we don't
want a caning to begin here
so we will call it an afternoon thank
you all and thank japan
president john f kennedy was